today on the Matt Walsh show the doj has
announced that the officer who shot
Ashley Babbitt will not be charged with
a crime in fact they won't even tell us
his name or give us any other
information about him or what happened
today we're going to take a close look
at this case try to figure out what did
happen why did the woman die and whether
or not it was justified also five
headlines including the Biden
Administration has its feet held to the
fire during the White House Press
briefing over its abortion policies that
doesn't happen every day and CNN brings
a trans Athlete on the air to explain
why men actually don't have an advantage
over women in sports plus Biden's U.N
Ambassador hates America it turns out
perhaps a bit of a conflict of interest
there we'll talk about that and so much
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
less than a day after armed robbery
suspect Dante Wright was shot by police
the name of the police officer who
pulled the trigger was publicly released
shortly after that her address was
leaked as well now her home is currently
surrounded by concrete barricades metal
fencing and armed police guards in order
to stop the violent mob from burning it
to the ground and perhaps killing anyone
who happens to be inside the house this
is the way it goes with every high
profile police shooting the name of the
police officer is quickly released soon
all of their other personal details
follow and then oftentimes as happened
with the officer in this case they're
charged with a crime well I shouldn't
say that it works this way with every
high profile police shooting there is
one quite notable exception it was
announced yesterday by the doj that the
officer who shot Ashley Babbitt one of
the pro-trump protesters at the Capitol
on January 6th will not be charged in
her death
the statement from the doj refers to
this man only as the U.S Capitol Police
Officer because his name was never made
public
we don't know his name four months later
and we know absolutely nothing about the
Federal Officer who shot an unarmed
woman in the capital compare that to
nearly any police shooting that BLM gets
upset about where we're told nearly
every personal detail about the officer
within hours of the shooting
before we even consider
the specific details of the shooting
which we will which left Ashley Babbitt
dead what few details we have as
officials refuse to tell us much of
anything really
it's already Unthinkable and outrageous
that this dichotomy exists there are two
systems in this country two tiers of
Justice one for the politically favored
one for the rest of us if you're shot by
police and BLM appoints you a martyr for
their cause the name of the officer will
be made public he'll likely be charged
with a crime unless the shooting was so
incontrovertibly above board that
prosecutors can't come up with a crime
that would theoretically cover it
meanwhile protesters will wreak havoc in
the streets and be allowed to do it and
the media will canonize you that's how
it goes in that case
what if you're shot by police and BLM
decides that your death doesn't matter
or even that you deserved what you got
then the officer's name will never be
given to the public the media will
quickly move on from the story the
protesters will sit on their hands and
the officer will be quickly clear of all
wrongdoing without any real explanation
either
whatever you think of the Ashley Babbitt
shooting
whether you believe it to be justified
or not and I'm not sure how you could be
sure that it is Justified given that the
powers that be haven't even bothered to
justify it
but whatever the case may be for you you
should not be okay with this state of
affairs
that you should at least agree that we
should know the officer's name just as
we know the names of the officers in
every other high profile incident
this is not merely about being fair or
having the same standard for everyone
though it is partially about that it's
also about understanding the true
motivations of the police officer who
fired the shot
this was obviously a politically charged
situation most of the writers and
protesters were right-wing Trump
supporters
many officers were there that day not
one of them saved this one
felt that it was necessary to start
shooting
is it possible that this officer had
ideological and political conflicts of
interest that he was pushed to take a
step that no other officer took due to
his political hatred for the people
there I have no idea that's the point
none of us know
could be couldn't be
these are the kinds of questions we
should ask these are the kinds of
questions the government would answer if
we truly lived in a free country where
everybody is equal under the law
now it's possible that this man who shot
her is an honest and straightforward guy
as honest as they come his motives as
pure as the driven snow but
they aren't giving us any information
about him
and so we're left only to speculate
about what his motivations might be
here's what we are being told and this
is about the sum of it really from the
doj statement yesterday I'll read it to
you not the whole thing but this is the
relevant portion
it says the focus of the criminal
investigation was to determine whether
Federal prosecutors could prove that the
officer violated any federal laws in
order to establish a violation of this
statute prosecutors must prove Beyond a
reasonable doubt that the officer acted
willfully to deprive Miss Babbitt of a
right protected by the Constitution or
other law
um the here the Fourth Amendment right
not to be subjected to an unreasonable
seizure prosecutors would have to prove
not only that the officer used force
that was constitutionally unreasonable
that the officer did so willfully which
the Supreme Court has interpreted to
mean that the officer acted with a bad
purpose to disregard the law
as this requirement has been interpreted
by the courts evidence that an officer
acted out of fear mistake Panic
misperception negligence or even poor
judgment cannot establish the high level
of intent required under Section 242.
the investigation revealed no evidence
to establish Beyond a reasonable doubt
that the officer willfully committed a
violation specifically the investigation
revealed no evidence to establish that
at the time of the officer fired a
single shot at Miss Babbitt the officer
did not reasonably believe that it was
necessary to do so in self-defense or
defense of the members of Congress and
others evacuating the house chamber
acknowledging the tragic loss of life
and offering condolences to miss
Babbitt's family the U.S attorney's
office and U.S Department of Justice
have therefore closed the investigation
into this matter
and that's it that's the end of it as
far as they're concerned
the the people who've been screaming
about police brutality for years and
accusing cops of being homicidal
lunatics are also perfectly satisfied
with that in this one case they're
satisfied with that in this one specific
case they're suddenly okay with an
unarmed woman being shot without any
given exp did you notice that they don't
actually tell us why he did it
they give a range of possible reasons
and don't tell us what the reason was
they say well it could have been out of
fear it could even be out of negligence
it could have been because he feared who
knows
well which is it
what did he say was his reason
we have zero transparency from the
government in this case
and not only is BLM okay with that
but if the BLM accounts on social media
or any any indication they're downright
happy that the woman is dead
but what about those of us who have
integrity and who actually care about
things like truth and justice you know
we in that Minority
though of course those of us who care
about truth and Justice we may never
scream for justice while we run out of a
burned out Foot Locker with an armful of
shoe boxes but we still care about it in
fact it's because we care about you uh
rather Justice that we wouldn't do that
those of us in that category what should
we think about this
well it's it's again it's hard to know
what to think because we're being told
so little about it all we have is the
video taken by somebody in the crowd
there is no doubt all kinds of
additional footage out there security
camera footage body cam footage I mean
it's it's a it's a federal government
building and there's police officers all
over the place they no doubt have tons
of footage but we haven't seen any of it
all we have is this and uh this is
disturbing of course because we're
watching a woman die but I think it's
important for us to watch it so because
this is all we have to go on and uh
let's watch it again now
please
afternoon
we start evacuating the other side
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's it
um that's all there is of the bet there
are a couple other angles of the
shooting taken from by by people in the
crowd but that's you know that's that's
it we can see the Babbitt was unarmed
and climbing through a door into a
hallway with armed police officers there
were also we can also see that there
were heavily armed and armored police
officers coming up the stairs behind her
she was literally surrounded on all
sides by armed police officers
one of the officers fired the shot
again the only officer on the scene that
day who apparently felt it necessary to
take that step
can we justify this shooting given the
circumstances
well if we can if we can
the argument in the unnamed cops favor
would have to go something like this
Ashley Babbitt was trespassing with an
unruly mob in a government building she
was given multiple warnings to leave the
area the warnings may or may not have
been verbal but the hallway was locked
and barricaded and there were police
officers guarding it with guns she knew
she was not supposed to keep going but
she did the officer didn't know what her
intentions were and made the best
decision he could in that high pressure
situation
okay that's what the argument in defense
of the shooting would sound like and I
have heard that exact argument from many
people including again the same people
who would in every other situation
reject that same argument
personally I am not convinced by that
argument at all
I think it's extraordinarily weak
yes she was trespassing yes it was very
Reckless to climb through that door no I
cannot defend that decision or tell you
what in the world could have possibly
been going through her mind when she
started to do that
but even so
this is a five foot two inch 110 pound
middle-aged unarmed woman
she was shot by a large male officer are
you telling me he couldn't have easily
taken her to the ground easily through
some other means
we know that she posed no physical risk
to him whatsoever
okay unless she's some sort of
ninja or something she posed no physical
risk to him we know that
can we really believe that he believed
that she did
she posed such a risk that he had to go
right to the gunshot
couldn't do anything else
and whatever he believed is it not
exceedingly clear that he could have
used any number of non-lethal means to
Halt her progress progress
here's another important question
did he personally verbally warn her that
he was going to shoot
yeah there were all kinds of visual cues
that she wasn't supposed to climb
through the door but did he actually
yell to her and say
stop or I will shoot you
if he did and she kept coming then that
might change things in his favor
certainly makes him look a little better
but if he didn't
if he didn't say anything and simply
executed her on the spot
then this looks even more like a
straight up murder of an unarmed Citizen
and Military Veteran by a federal law
enforcement officer
now we could answer that question by the
way about what the officer did or didn't
say if more footage was released or even
if they would just tell us
they know okay
Department of Justice Capitol Police the
politicians even the media
I guarantee you all of them know who
that guy is and what exactly happened
they're not telling us
and the fact that they haven't told us
if he gave her a warning and said stop
or I'll shoot you and she kept coming
you'd think they'd probably tell us that
the fact that they're not telling us
that and not telling us anything else
that would seem to basically answer the
question no there was no warning that's
my guess
and we're left only to guess my guess is
very educated guess reasonable guess
there was no warning
from him verbally he just shot her
thank you
to my mind shooting an unarmed person
who poses no reasonable lethal threat to
you without warning
um is murder
now here's what we can say though
if this shooting was justified
then
a great many of the high profile
shootings that BLM has rioted over were
also Justified
any logically consistent argument you
can make that would validate Babbitt's
killing would also validate the killing
of many BLM Martyrs all in one Fell
Swoop that much we know
she was in the process of committing a
crime okay well so was George Floyd so
was Michael Brown in the vast majority
of these high profile cases a crime was
being committed that's why the cops were
there
she was given warnings well we don't
know if she was or not but we know that
Jacob Blake was
I mean he had guns pointed at him and
they were screaming at him over and over
again in his face stop stop stop and he
didn't stop until they finally pulled
the trigger
she was unarmed but could have still
theoretically posed a lethal threat well
BLM has protested the killing of even
armed suspects like Dion K in DC was
running towards officers with his gun
drawn
they protested that
many others were not armed but were
still presenting themselves as clear
physical threats like rayshard Brooks in
Atlanta who got into a fight with
officers and stole one of their tasers
she should have known better okay well
should Dante Wright not have known
better than to push away the officers
resist arrest and climb back into his
vehicle
if Ashley Babbitt brought her death on
herself
if she is to blame
if she is not the victim but the
perpetrator who reaped the consequences
of her own actions which seems to be the
the opinion of most people out there
certainly on the left but even a lot of
people on the right
then the same applies to every name I
just listed and then some
oh but she was an insurrectionist trying
to take over a government building you
say
well if that's what makes the difference
if we're saying that what gives cops a
license to start spraying bullets is
that
then I would put a great many BLM and
antifa Riders directly in the line of
fire
though in their case you know they've
been allowed to wage assaults on federal
buildings for months on end sometimes
even take over government buildings like
police stations and burn them to the
ground without a single shot being fired
at them ever
but that brings us back to where we
started
Justice in two tears
A system that favors some and not others
Ashley Babbitt falls on the losing side
of that coin
and no matter what they might say or
excuses they might offer in the minds of
BLM and the media in our government
that is why her death is not an outrage
or a crime
it's getting out of our five headlines
[Music]
all right um let me I just have to say
this at the to begin with you know I
don't I don't often do this very rarely
have I done this but I have to issue a
retraction and a bit of an editorial
correction in the in the if you listen
to the show yesterday which you better
have in the daily cancellation we talked
about
the made up gibberish language of the
left and how it gets more and more
absurd with the pronouns and now they
have Neo pronouns for people who
identify as hot dog buns and clouds and
skyscrapers and horses
um and you know I I gave a little bit of
my own personal background in my own my
own history of trauma saying that when I
grew up I had four sisters in the house
and my two older sisters
um had their own it wasn't pronouns but
they had their own gibberish languages
they would make up and then speak to
each other in front of me in this
made-up language to torment me because I
never knew what they were saying
and that's what I that's the claim I
made I did get a text message from my
younger sister one of my younger sisters
last night who listened to the show and
wanted me to know that it wasn't my
older sisters who had the made-up
language it was her and our youngest
sister who had it
so I had I got that wrong
and she clarified to me that um he's my
two younger sisters they are the ones
who had the made-up language and they
called it I didn't know this they called
it the I think she said it in the text
they called it the a annoying language
because every made-up word ended in a
and um they just used it to annoy
everybody in the house so
I have to issue that retraction because
the thing is
if I've set my family and they boycott
the show
I lose half my audience and I can't
allow that to happen
all right let's start here we're going
to start with with maybe the best
question I've ever heard asked
best line of questioning I've ever heard
um at a White House Press Conference
and that's not saying a lot because very
rarely are there
worthwhile questions that are asked I
mean most of what said at a White House
Press Conference the questions that are
asked aren't even really questions right
they're just softballs teeing up at
least if it's a democratic
Administration softball's teeing up the
spokesperson to say whatever they want
to say but in this case I thought this
was uh this was really good this is
apparently
EWTN reporter Owen Jensen somehow
they've allowed EWTN that's the Catholic
news organization they've allowed them
in the building
probably not for long now
and uh let's let's take a listen so
today as you well know the Biden
administration at HHS started the
reversal of the Trump administration's
ban on abortion referrals at title 10
Family Planning clinics so my first
question
why does the Biden Administration insist
that pro-life Americans pay for
abortions and violate their conscience
well first that's not an accurate
depiction of what happens so let me and
I know we want to be accurate around
here uh none of the funds appropriated
under this title shall be used in
programs where abortion is a method of
Family Planning that is written into the
Public Health Service Act and it
specifically states that
indirect subsidies mine is fungible that
can't be traced we know that come on
that is not how it works that is the law
so I'm stating with the law is and how
it is implemented legally by these
organizations and the reason I though
since you gave me the opportunity uh the
reason why the president took these
steps is because uh he believes that
advancing equity for all including
people of color and others who have been
historically underserved marginalized
and adversely affected by persistent
poverty and inequality can be helped by
these actions and by focusing on
advancing equity in the title 10 program
we can create opportunities for the
Improvement of communities that have
been historically underserved which
benefits everyone that's how these
fundings are used in communities you
talk about Equity if I may interrupt how
is it Equity how is it fighting systemic
racism when abortion we well know
disproportionately affects minority
children again funding cannot be used
from this for abortion but Access to
Health Care access to health care and
communities and communities that have
been marginalized underserved adversely
affected by persistent poverty is always
going to be something the president
fights for okay I think I've answered
your question Alex well she didn't
really answer but but so two great
points being raised questions being
asked
um by the reporter there
and one is about the funding now now she
says oh yeah well they're funding but
it's it's not going
you know it's going to uh Healthcare
clinics and Facilities that provide
abortions but it's but the funding can't
go to the abortion
and the rejoinder from the reporter is
correct that money is fungible so
anytime you hear that you know that it's
bogus and we've been hearing this as a
justification for the federal funding of
Planned Parenthood for decades now you
know we get half a billion dollars a
year
to uh Planned Parenthood
um as they murder hundreds of thousands
of babies a year
and of course we we continue to
hand over these bags full of money we
make these uh these these sugar daddy
payments the government the taxpayer the
sugar daddy for Planned Parenthood we
continue to do that even after we had a
republican Administration we had a
republican Congress and Republican
Administration for two years
they didn't do they didn't do a damn
thing about it
but anyway the the justification is that
yeah we give half a billion but it
doesn't go to the abortions
okay but money is fungible
that's the point
so it doesn't even really make sense to
say yeah if we
if you use the money to fund this aspect
of their operation
then that frees them up to put other
money towards the abortion aspect so by
funding one part of it you are
effectively funding the other
and then the second line of questioning
about if you if you care about Equity
inequality uh and all of that
and you want to protect minority
communities
well we know that abortion when we say
abortion disproportionately affects
minority communities what that means is
that Minority babies are being killed at
a disproportionate rate
and if not for abortion
there would be many millions more
minority people in the the in the uh the
country today
so it's it's hard to see that as a
positive
for any minority Community or any
community at all
that they've successfully exterminated
so many of their own children
all right let's move to uh
number two CNN had a segment with a
trans athlete they call this person I
think on on the screen what do they say
here yeah trans female okay so they call
this person a trans female athlete which
I assume means it's a male who
identifies as a woman but you see how
sex and gender have once again become
interchangeable after they spent the
last I don't know 40 or 50 years telling
us that sex and gender are two different
things and they're not interchangeable
you know being a woman is not exactly
the same thing as being a female and a
person can be a female doesn't
necessarily make them a woman that's
what they said for you know last 40 or
50 years and now over the last couple of
years what they they've gone back and uh
and said never mind actually it's the
same
I know we screamed at you for 50 years
that it's two different things but turns
out now basically it's interchangeable
woman female same thing sex gender same
thing
so but that's the least of the problems
I think with this segment and um let's
let's just listen to this madness the
simplistic version is that those born
male have a natural physiological
advantage that also includes differing
levels of testosterone you know the
argument your response to that is what
yeah it's uh it's a nonsense argument so
depends on how much time you want let me
get into the weeds because I can
literally spend hours on this how about
30 how about 30 seconds yeah so the
first thing is
um testosterone your natural internally
produced and Dodges testosterone has
zero impact on your athletic performance
and we know that but we didn't know that
until 2013.
because everyone just assumed that while
testosterone is why men are bigger
stronger faster but when we finally
studied it there's no relationship
between just natural testosterone and
performance so why is testosterone band
well every body produces a different
amount and when you add to it through
exogenous means doping there is a
performance Advantage but when you take
a body's natural amount and you drop
below it there tends to be a performance
disadvantage for example in one study
they found in this Elite set of male
athletes some men below the women's
average for testosterone were competing
at no competitive disadvantage with men
that had 40 times as much testosterone
right uh the first problem here maybe
the biggest problem are the glasses
there who goes on on television
wearing glasses like that
now I know you might point out that I
have made some interesting fashion
choices with what I choose to wear when
I'm on uh in front of the camera but
come on
give me a break that's uh what
rainbow rainbow glasses
but this is what you what you're seeing
there is the left doing what the left
does
um and that is distracting from the main
point
and what they're going to do is really
on any issue especially where they know
they have an indefensible position which
is every issue particularly when it
comes to gender they're going to home in
on one specific argument
and what they say in that area will be
false
but it's also going to be almost
entirely beside the point
but then the the strategy is that the
other side on the right we get sucked
into having this argument over this
basically irrelevant detail
because what they're saying there is so
wrong and we can't we feel like we can't
Leap Frog over that we have to you know
argue over that so the claim that
testosterone doesn't give
athletes an advantage is obviously
ridiculous but
it's almost beside the point we could
even it's not about testosterone is just
one
one minor advantage
in comparison to all the other
advantages that men have
they don't even talk about
any of those other advantages
now it's all about testosterone and so
they're going to pull out all the
studies and they're going to say this
study over here said this about
testosterone
they're going to start using a lot of
complicated sounding words like
exogenistic and all these kinds of words
to make it sound like they're um they
have the science supporting them and
they're they're taking a very nuanced
and intelligent
position
and this is all what they're actually
claiming is that men don't have any
innate biological advantage in sports it
is so insane
there's there's
it it is
as crazy as claiming that the Earth is
flat
I know a lot of positions get compared
to that oh these are like flat earthers
no this is actual flat arthurism this is
as crazy as that
it is that divorce from reality
obviously men have an advantage in
sports
that's why you take any sport and you
find that the that the best men are
always better
than the best women in most sports I
should say you want to make you want to
talk about gymnastics or those it might
be different
but when it comes to the traditional
competitive sports
racing you know basketball football
those kinds of sports Wrestling Boxing
one-on-one where it's all about strength
and stamina
pure athleticism men are always the best
men are always substantially better than
the best women and in fact men a few
notches down are going to be
substantially better than the best women
that's why you take any D3
uh basketball team from college and you
put them against the best WNBA players
we all know they would dominate
the score would be 85-0
we all know that
go to any state
look at the uh the the track and field
um Statistics and Records in any state
in the Union anyone
and what you're going to find is that
all of the fastest times belong to men
always always
everywhere and for all time
why is that because men have
dozens and dozens of physical advantages
and it's and testosterone isn't even the
beginning of it
you're talking about muscle structure
bone structure everything down you know
even things like women having wider hips
I mean things like that
every every part of us
as as men is is going to be going to be
different from women
we as as a man you are male down to your
very bones literally and women are women
down to their bones
and all through that you find
differences
and in so many of these cases the
differences give advantages to men in
most competitive Sports
all right
um
let's take a look at uh okay we got to
play this the uh our U.N Ambassador
Linda Thomas Greenfield is Phil is her
name
she because she's a Democrat and she was
appointed by Democrat of course she
hates our country hates it deeply
and made that clear in a recent address
let's listen to what she had to say
I've seen for myself how the original
sin of slavery weaved white supremacy
into our founding documents and
principles but I also shared these
stories to offer up an Insight a simple
truth I've learned over the years
racism is not the problem of the person
who experiences it those of us who
experience racism cannot and should not
internalize it despite the impact it can
have on our everyday lives
racism is the problem of the racist and
it is the problem of the society that
produces the racist and in today's world
that's every society in America that
that takes many forms it's the white
supremacy that led to the senseless
killing of George Floyd Brianna Taylor
Amman Aubry and so many other black
Americans
yeah racism led to the death of George
Floyd of course we you know we get that
that claim from
everyone on the left it's they've never
even tried to give any evidence for it
they never do
in in what way you have evidence that
Derek Chauvin is racist and that he
killed George Floyd on purpose due to
his racial animus really
if you have that evidence hey uh Linda
Greenfield if you've got that evidence
you better give it it's probably too
late now but uh you better hand that
over to the appropriate authorities
because they the the prosecutors
Prosecuting Derek's children right now
they don't have that evidence they
haven't produced it
they produced a shred of evidence that
any of this had anything to do with race
that would be a bombshell if they had it
I mean if they could produce something I
don't know what what that would be but
something indicating
this was racially motivated that changes
the complexion of everything
no pun intended
but there's no evidence of that so
um no big deal just our U.N Ambassador
you know smearing cops is racist
smearing the entire country as racist
of course if that is your view
you're not
fit to hold any public office especially
not fit to be the UN ambassador
you cannot
lead people that you hate
you cannot lead
something that you hit you can't lead an
organization that you hate
now if you work for a company and you
hate that company
and then you're made you're put in a
position of authority it's gonna be bad
news
because you're in a position of
authority in a company that you hate
same goes for a country
if you're leading a country that you
despise like Linda Thomas Greenfield
despises it
um
nothing good is going to happen
that's why why do you think it's one of
the reasons why you look at any City run
by Democrat
all of the cities that are in shambles
across the country every single one all
of them run by democrats
a lot of reasons for that one of the
reasons though is that they hate their
cities they hate the people in the
cities they hate the country that the
city is uh is is located in
they hate it all they hate the history
of the city
and that really comes through right
like anything else if you're if you're
in charge of taking care of something
and you and you either don't care about
it or actively hate it
bad things are going to happen although
she did say I have to say uh listening
to that clip again I noticed one thing
that she said that I actually agree with
and then but she moved on from it and I
don't think she understands the
implications of what she said but but
she said that she was talking about
racism and she said it's a it's in every
society
well you know yes actually you're right
about that
racism is
um comes from like any other form of
hatred or anything else it comes from
flaws in human nature and which means
doesn't mean that every person is racist
it just means that you're going to find
that
any kind of hatred whether it's racial
hatred any other form of hatred you're
gonna find
elements of that in any society she's
right about that
but what that means is that if you go to
Africa
you're going to find a hell of a lot of
racism okay you go to Asia
Health lotterys you go to India a lot of
racism the Middle East a lot of racism
it is a it is a a problem that you find
across the globe and in fact
in a lot of non-western countries it's a
lot worse than it is here
a lot
and a lot more socially accepted
so that part I agree with but um as I
said if if people on the left were to
stop and consider the implications of
that and what that actually means then
maybe they would hate America a little
bit less but uh all right we're gonna
get to reading the comments in just well
nowhere to get there now actually we'll
just move right to be reading the
comments
um Joan says sadly all the victims of
these violent criminals are completely
ignored where's the me too movement
standing up for these women
yeah the metoo move man just like BLM
any of these movements on the left
um of course they don't meet to movement
pretends to be standing for women's
rights and speaking out specifically for
for victims women female victims of
violent crime
and harassment and they don't they don't
care about that
just like BLM is a big grift people at
the top are making lots of money we know
the one of the founders of BLM just
bought what is it four different houses
all in white neighborhoods of course
uh the grifter's in charge of now me too
has not been as profitable a grift as
BLM is but still pretty profitable
they don't care if they did yeah they'd
be speaking up and saying what about the
women here how do they feel
can we at least hear from them
and and if they don't want to come
forward and here's the thing
a lot they would they might very very
likely decline the opportunity to come
forward and speak
but if they do it's only because they're
afraid of what would happen to them if
they were to kind of the the woman that
George Floyd
um
point
put at gunpoint after after forcing his
way into our house
if that woman whoever she is
probably is not going to want to come
out
and say how she feels about George Floyd
and how it makes her feel to walk by
murals with this guy's face every day
but the reason that she wouldn't want to
say it I'm I would guess
is because it would put her life in
danger
what does that tell us
that's all the more reason why you would
think me too would speak up on their
behalf if they care but they don't
um kvg says two things can be true at
once Dante was a bad human being and the
cop screwed up
sure I don't think anyone we the cop
admits pretty much on the spot when you
listen to the video that it was an
accident
and so an accident is a mistake a
screw-up you know this I don't think
anyone is denying that
um
absolutely degenerate kind of ironic
username given the comment here says
children are too wholesome for this
world Matt your daughter is adorable
yeah you know what they really are it's
kind of heartbreaking as a parent they
don't tell you this part of a parenting
do you this is one thing that this
undercurrent of pain
um that comes it's sort of this it's a
it's a kind of a sweet loving pain but
it is pain that you feel as a parent
seeing your children in their innocence
and knowing
that it won't last knowing that one day
they'll be as jaded and corrupted As You
Are
I have moments like this all the time
with my kids at A Moment Like This
actually this morning with my son
because I went into the room to say bye
to him before I left for work and he had
this magazine that that his mom bought
from the store with pictures of King
Kong and Godzilla you know it's just
like one of those movie magazines and um
he had selected a bunch of pages and
marked them
that he wanted to sit with
when I got home from work he said you
wanted to sit with me and look at these
these specific pages so he told me when
I got from work there's just a bunch of
awesome pictures he needs me to see and
he's looking forward to that and of
course I said oh buddy that's awesome
you know I can't wait but I also had
this Pang of sadness again
like man this kid is so innocent and
sweet that this is what he's this is
what he's doing with his day is he's
looking at pictures of Godzilla and King
Kong looking forward to watch look at
the magazine with Daddy
um
but you know it won't last that's the
thing that's the sadness that's where it
comes in
it was a sappy moment we don't get those
very often on the show I feel like I
have to to move to something else here
we go
um another comment says this is my first
time commenting so I I will inevitably
be banned for not commenting earlier
no you're banned for thinking that I
would ban you for something so petty
that's why you're banned but you are
banned for the record
another comment says Matt I was unsure
of your show back when you were
streaming in your car now you're my
favorite show on daily wire you pull no
punches keep up the great work so you're
unsure just because I was in my car
elitist you think I didn't have anything
worthwhile to say only because I was a
maniac screaming at my car dashboard
really
you know what that gets you get your
banned of course
and finally Jackson says congratulations
on 700 episodes
I didn't even realize I read these
comments and uh that's how I realized I
was at 700 episodes big milestone I
didn't plan any celebration
um
here I will joyously throw these pens in
the air in celebration here's my
celebration for 700 episodes you ready
that was pretty exciting
good all right now a quick word from
expressvpn listen we know that everyone
should have the right to express
themselves freely but we know also sadly
that big Tech has opted for silencing
people and censorship uh and we know
that this is a lot of this is
politically motivated and what does that
mean it means we have to fight back and
to fight back against big tax control
the internet I use expressvpn you ever
wondered how free to access Tech Giants
make all their money they make billions
of it well they do it by tracking your
searches or video history everything you
click on and by building a profile of
you they then sell off your sensitive
data and that's how they're making money
off of you without your consent without
your knowing it when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you you uh you make Anonymous much of
your online presence by hiding your IP
address that means
your activity is more difficult to trace
more difficult to sell to advertisers
what's more expressive evanning Crips
100 of your network data sort of
protects you from eavesdroppers and
curtains and cyber criminals you know
that big Tech hates you so don't just
let let them profit off of you in this
way take action get expressvpn revoke
big text right to your data secure your
internet with the VPN that I trust for
online protection visit expressvpn.com
Walsh that's exp r e s s vpn.com Walsh
to get three months free with my
exclusive link that's again
expressvpn.com Walsh right now and learn
more
also it's episode five already we can't
get enough of Candace Owens or her new
show and uh every episode has been great
and getting better each each week this
week uh I think it's gonna be the best
of all because she's gonna be hosting
comedian and podcaster Adam Carolla you
can tune in uh you don't want to miss
this conversation and if you want to
tune in of course you become a daily
wire member you can watch that way or
you can also get Candace Owens in your
Twitter feed uh Apple Spotify wherever
you listen to your podcast so if you
need some Candace Owens in your podcast
feed uh look no further head over to
Apple podcast or Spotify And subscribe
today be sure to leave a five star
review if you like what you hear now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign I think will be a brief and
relatively painless cancellation we
turned to an article in the Washington
Post an article in which your your
humble your humble podcast host yours
truly is personally featured
the headline is United pledge to
diversify its pilot pipeline outrage
from conservative pundits was Swift
now I should tell you that I didn't know
about this article or that I was
mentioned until I it was posted to
Twitter by a guy named tauren Ellis who
tagged me in his tweet Ellis tweeted
quote here are three propped up mediocre
white men that should kick rocks Matt
Walsh Tucker Carlson and Pierce Morgan
for attempting to devalue dni I think
dni stands for diversity and inclusion
needless to say if I called Ellis a
quote mediocre black man he would cry
racist and only you know that's because
he's allowed to use language like that
uh but I'm not the rules are very clear
Ellis by the way is a diversity and
inclusion strategist by trade I'm still
not sure what A diversity and inclusion
strategist does exactly
I guess a company hires you and then you
give them arbitrary quotas to fill like
you say well let's see this company
needs nine more black people two Asians
12 women
tell you what let's spice it up a bit
and get a get a non-binary lesbian
Vietnamese pirate on staff as well
that'll be 95 000 thank you
the process may not work exactly like
that but I think that's the general idea
in any case all that to say this is how
I discovered that I was outraged that I
was outraged at United you see I'm quite
often included in these articles about
conservative outrage and conservative
backlash the strategy from the media is
pretty obvious it always follows the
same pattern someone on the left or some
company on the left in this case does
something crazy and stupid
the media knows that it can't defend the
crazy stupid thing on its own merits so
instead they go in through the back door
attempting to indirectly defend it by
pretending that only we bigoted hateful
insane conservative pundits are opposed
to this crazy stupid thing
for the record much of the time
outrage is not the right word for how I
feel about these crazy stupid things
sometimes it is okay I am indeed
outraged for example about the children
being indoctrinated into left-wing
gender Theory and then drugged and
mutilated
I've been included in conservative
outrage articles about that and
accurately so
the physical and sexual abuse of
children does outrage me
you might even say that I'm a full-blown
snowflake when it comes to child abuse I
I am very upset about it and angry that
much I admit it offends me it does
as for United deciding to recruit based
on race and gender rather than Merit I'm
not outraged if I was a passenger on the
first plane that that crashes because
this pilot is being because it's being
piloted by someone who was hired to fill
a quota then yeah I'd be outraged about
that
but I'm not going to be on that plane
because I'm not going to fly United
because I prefer not to die if I can
help it
nonetheless I was included in the
outrage pundit Brigade without my
consent here's the relevant portion of
the article it says
criticism of the plan suggested United
was prioritizing the wrong qualities and
in many cases overlooked the fact that
Pilots would still have to undergo
extensive training to be eligible for a
job daily wire columnist Matt Walsh
penned an opinion piece titled United
offers passengers exciting opportunity
to die in diverse and Equitable plane
crash
Fox News host Tucker Carlson tackled the
issue the day after United's
announcement accusing the airline of
prioritizing identity politics over
safety
quoting him it says so if hiring on the
basis of irrelevant criteria will over
time get people killed and it will why
are they demanding it because they don't
care they're ideologues they're
suffering from an incurable brain
disease called wokeness and Piers Morgan
who resigned from Good Morning America
last month after criticizing Megan
Duchess of Sussex wrote In The Daily
Mail that white male Pilots were being
discriminated against by the airlines
plan okay now I wouldn't call my
headline quoted there as outraged I did
think it was pretty clever though and
I'm grateful for the shout out but what
I what I really want to focus on for a
moment is a quote earlier in the article
from the spokesman for United Airlines
and as far as I know this is the first
time they've come out and given a longer
explanation of this plan and defense of
it
and so In fairness I'll read that to you
here's the spokesman said he said our
commitment to diversity is about
recruiting from the deepest pool
possible of exceptional and qualified
candidates who want to pursue a career
as a commercial airline pilot
particularly those who otherwise may not
have attempted to do so due to a variety
of factors primarily Financial barriers
we believe that we're going to be a
better stronger Airline because of this
and we also understand that our pilot
group needs to be needs to better
reflect the communities that we serve
now this of course is nonsense
um
the point is that the United didn't just
say that they want to make sure everyone
has a fair shot at being a pilot they
didn't just say that they're going to go
into underserved communities and
recruits
nobody would object to that plan
most of us probably assumed they were
already doing stuff like that if they
weren't it's an easy thing to start
doing
the problem is that they set a quota a
goal
they have an actual percentage in mind
for the number of women and minorities
that will be in their training pipeline
fifty percent is the number they want
so here again is the question
if all they want to do is find the most
qualified people
and are expanding their search to that
end how can they know ahead of time that
50 of the most qualified people will be
women and minorities
they might hope that it's 50 percent
but how do they know that it will be
they obviously can't know that and it's
almost certainly not going to work out
like that
if then they fulfill their 50 goal it
will be because they put other
considerations above considerations of
Merit and skill
this is another equality equality of
outcome versus equality of opportunity
situation everybody agrees
with equality of opportunity
we're turning something controversial
which doesn't need to be controversial
if you simply said all people of all
Races Nations and Creeds and Sexes
should have the opportunity to be a
pilot or a firefighter or an actor or
whatever other arbitrarily selected
occupation
um if that's all you said nobody would
disagree
we could all shake hands and be friends
probably Not Shake Hands given the
lingering coveted paranoia but we could
all elbow bump and be friends that is a
non-controversial opinion and a worthy
goal and it's not a problem
but when you say that a certain
pre-ordained percentage of the people
who actually earn these jobs and titles
should be a certain race or sex then you
have left this non-controversial opinion
and worthy goal and fallen into a pit
where everything is dumb and nothing
makes sense and planes crash because the
pilot was incompetent but filled a quota
and the media pretends that only
conservative pundits are upset about it
and so for that reason
The Washington Post of course is
canceled and uh the diversity and
strategists from before I forget his
name already
all canceled and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring our supervising producers
are Mathis Glover and Robert Sterling
our technical director is Austin Stevens
production manager Pavel vadoski the
show is edited by Sasha tolmachov our
audio is mixed by Mike cormina hair
makeup is done by Mika Geneva and our
production coordinator is McKenna Waters
the Matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
CNN admits on a hidden camera that it
hyped kovid for Ratings the LM NYC
lambasts blm's founder for embezzling
lots of money without giving them a cut
and ice cream melts over white supremacy
check it out on the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
thank you